now uh of course uh you're a mom now yes
uh beautiful number one mom my number
one mom beautiful girl uh and and what's
amazing about you is you you had this
this baby and then
weeks later you're back working again it
was back on on snl six weeks later right
which is you know it's tough did you
like start working out like crazy did
you did you do because you read a lot of
celebrities like they feel like they get
right back to work and they those ladies
in la they amy poehler and i always call
it l.a tight those ladies in l.a that
have a baby and then like
right
but no i tried uh i you know i tried to
work out pretty soon after my daughter
was born i went to the gym i was like
all right i'm going to jump rope like i
used to jump rope like a boxer and i'll
get really skinny and i went the first
time and i got my thing out and i was
like jumping rope and i was like jump
jump jump
peed my pants a little bit
packed up my belongings yeah
my dignity
my junk is ruined
your junk is ruined what are you talking
about what do you mean you're junkies my
junk is ruined it's ruined
oh wow really the junk okay i've never
heard that i've never heard someone say
my junk is ruined junk
is ruined yeah okay do guys have junk or
is it just the ladies
he referred to uh his situation he
referred to it as his hang which his
hand
what did he what did he say well he was
you know he was quoting yates and then
he
[Laughter]
okay your uh your daughter alice is a
year old now yeah a little over a year
old and oh this means halloween right
are you gonna get into halloween yeah
she did halloween last year but she
doesn't know that she did and um well
when they're that young you can pretty
much just like put a bucket on their
head that's the thing that's awesome is
there's a little window of time when you
can decide what they're going to be
before they want to be
bob or whatever so it's like gosh it's
going to be a diane sawyer no it
wouldn't be
but she's bald so if he's either going
to be uh a pumpkin or the old man from
benny hill
the old man that benny hill's always
doing that to i love that guy what are
your kids going to be i don't uh my
daughter just said i want to be a kitty
cat see she knows already yeah but i was
i don't know i'm always like i i just
was obsessed with robots when i all i
wanted to be every year was a robot when
i was a kid so i'd always ask for a
giant refrigerator box
and punch holes in it and then walk
around and go like i will destroy you i
am a robot and now
now i'm a robot yeah yeah i still think
he's either c-3po or a colonial lady
what's a colonial label like someone who
was like churning butter i had like a
yeah like a bonnet i'll die at the age
of 35. you know
i have no proper nutrition
fun little quips like that
right okay i can't vote in this country
all right
what a fun character for you uh
now uh i you kindly invited me which may
have been a huge mistake to do a guest
spot on your show yes
playing myself very very important
sweeps episode yeah i got the part of
conan o'brien yeah which i was angry and
we auditioned like 10 years yeah i know
that was your fourth choice
after donnie most from happy days and a
few other people but anyway i got the
coveted conan o'brien spot and then i'm
and so i was slipping through the part
and it's actually kind of a funny it
seemed like a funny idea which is that
uh tracy uh alec baldwin you do tracy's
character is he plays this guy who's a a
movie star a big comic movie star who's
fallen on hard times a little bit
because he's gone nuts and he uh now
he's on this tv show and so he's he's
booked now to go on your show right uh
but unfortunately uh the day that he is
booked to do the show he's having some
trouble with his medication so he's
really kind of whacked out and i don't
want him on because the last time he was
on the show he tried to step down he
tried to stab me right
so anyway he comes on the show and uh
and it's interesting we have i'm reading
through the script and in the script
conan o'brien uh used to have a
relationship with your character sure my
character used to go out with conan
o'brien yeah yeah why not yeah
it makes me look good yeah i like it
uh all right let's uh so this is a scene
i guess it's the scene where you're
you've just taken trace china i'm trying
to get him calmed down enough to do your
show and i'm trying to hide him right
and then i come along let's take a look
at this uh clip from an upcoming episode
of 30 rock
you want me mr brew man we can box the
door all right all right all right
hey liz what's up
oh hi conan how are you good
you still going out with that guy from
the pager store
oh dennis
yeah
you still um how's your wife
let's not do this elizabeth
[Music]
so is uh tracy
okay and stuff
absolutely
the vocal warm-ups
i'll tell them you came by
okay
i like the intensity the smaller one
they've
got man there's some sexual chemistry
and you get conan o'brien in the scene
but you haven't met between tracy and
that mirror i like that yeah that's the
sexual yeah i like that i get to say the
line let's not do this elizabeth
[Laughter]
a tone i would never have in real life
when talking to a former girlfriend i'd
be like i quit it cut it out
cut it out
uh it's a really funny show 30 rock airs
wednesday nights at eight on nbc so
check it out tina fey thank you so much
for being here continued success stephen
wright coming up and take a break i'll
be right back